we unleashed something powerful we call
her the ghost she could destroy the
world I'd love to help you I'm under
house arrest we'll have you home by
lunch I'm gonna come with you guys
[Music]
hang on
great job back there thanks I gonna say
the same thing to me good job thank you
skillful agile and fast
they call her the wasa she seems intense
Scott he unleashed something powerful
we need your help oh boy
you owe us and man and the wasp teaming
up
oh man and the wasps everywhere July 6
we unleashed something powerful we have
to stop her
if you want to do something right you
make a list
we have to team up - we got to fight dos
three ghosts that seems like should be
part of two - eh
watch this
Oh also we have to save the world that's
major we can't forget that
like bad guys like you
mess it up every time
maybe you just need a partner
dr. PIM I actually heard what happened
to you it's crazy could be closed stole
your tech deal the chassis crash this
again
and man the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
she seems more intense
[Applause]
we unleashed something powerful
the chance to back this together there
is another person I can take maybe I'm
doing it wrong you have no idea what I'm
capable of
[Applause]
she just wanted to give me a hug wish me
luck really
watch this
[Applause]
sorry I'm messing Rob wish I had a suit
even with like minimal powers or maybe
even just a suit with no powers yeah
you